[Music]
this morning a london police officer who
protected u.s diplomats was sent to
prison for a murder that stunned the
british public
sarah everhard disappeared back in march
and was found dead a week later officer
wayne cousins pleaded guilty and now we
know exactly how he abducted her showing
his badge and then driving her away
holly williams is at the courthouse in
london with more on this story holly
this is so sad and upsetting to hear
good morning
good morning or the abduction rape and
murder of sarah everard by a serving
police officer in march touched a raw
nerve in this country angering women who
do not feel safe on their own streets
today in this court her killer was
sentenced to life in prison with no
parole the harshest punishment possible
in the united kingdom
sarah everard's brutal murder unleashed
an outpouring of grief from people who'd
never met her and a vigil near where she
disappeared when police tried to shut it
down citing covert regulations these
tactics added fuel to the fire
everard was walking home from a friend's
house down well-lit streets in central
london when a police officer falsely
arrested her kidnapped raped and
strangled her and burned her remains in
a forest do you know where it is
wayne cousins pleaded guilty but
originally told detectives he'd been
pressured into abducting a woman by a
criminal gang after getting into debt
and didn't know what they'd done with
sarah everard
and they said
they said you've done good
cousins was a diplomatic protection
officer whose last shift was outside the
u.s embassy he'd been accused on
multiple occasions of indecent exposure
but didn't lose his job
sarah everard was caring she was funny
she was clever said her mother in a
statement to the court calling her my
precious little girl in her last hour
she was faced with brutality and terror
i am haunted by the horror of it the
british government and police say
they're trying to make the streets safer
for women but this month an elementary
school teacher sabina nessa was murdered
as she walked to meet a friend her body
dumped in a nearby park
the the chair of the police federation
here said that sarah everard's killer
has brought disgrace to the uniform but
inside the court today sarah everard's
parents hugged police officers after the
sentence was handed down
nate
glad justice was served holly williams
in london thank you